Costa Rica wants to be carbon neutral by
2021 it's already well on the way when
it comes to protecting the rainforest
now it's focused on reducing greenhouse
gas emissions generated by coffee
production climate friendly coffee is
also good for business the German Get
Set Development Agency is helping the
country with the conversion we know the
project is quite innovative no one else
is doing it yet we hope that the
production methods will allow coffee
farmers to market their product is
something they make unlike any other
coffee in the world Coffee is relatively
expensive in Costa Rica because of high
wages and the fact that the country
promotes quality instead of quantity
the coffee may be more expensive but its
quality is ensured by the National
Coffee Institute ich fe which has been
working to improve it further and make
it more climate-friendly it's a highly
scientific process for example farmers
send samples of ailing plants to the
Institute where scientists look for
efficient treatments such as more
ecologically sound fertilizers and the
coffee that is produced is subjected to
extensive quality control
[Music]
new types of plants are grown on the
test fields nearby this new plant from
Brazil is showing promise it bears an
unusually large number of beans these
are the three year old plants this is
the entire harvest this isn't normal for
one of our traditional plants usually
they need longer to produce so many
coffee beans and the leaves are bigger
nearly double the size of traditional
leaves and they're very tough that helps
deter fungus infections from developing
quickly a media Acosta's job is to
convince the farmers to adopt the
improved ecological practices besides
using these plants they also need to
change how they cultivate them they have
to increase the distance between the
plants change the fertilizer and provide
more shade those are big changes and
most start with small steps farmers
receive regular visits this time in a
row see one of the smaller plantations a
Custer is meeting facility nice at the
Finca summary the world of coffee
farmers is a small one here in Costa
Rica so senior anis explains that the
harvest is already well underway even
though it's the middle of the rainy
season
we're definitely noticing climate change
we didn't used to start harvesting until
September now it's only June that's
incredible many local coffee farmers are
here today to attend a workshop that
will teach them production methods that
are more climate-friendly most emissions
come from fertilizer especially nitrogen
fertilizer if the farmers can spray more
efficiently they will produce less
damaging greenhouse gases today they're
learning proper dose
and how to cover a hectare of coffee
plants most efficiently they're
practicing with water at the finger
they're also learning how to keep co2
emissions low by planting large shade
trees this trunk contains about 50%
carbon and the tree is constantly going
through the process of photosynthesis
that means it absorbs carbon from the
atmosphere through its leaves in the
form of co2 as it grows year after year
it absorbs more and more carbon some
trees absorb more than others the ones
with dense wood are best the coffee
producers are always curious and they
want to know more and more sometimes
they're skeptical of new methods but
they're willing to try they'll say maybe
in that small corner over there I'll try
it and so step by step they're learning
by doing and then they go over to a
neighbor and say look what I've done I
didn't think it would work but it's one
farmer who can show his neighbors what
he's already done is Oscar Chacon his
finger las lajas is in the center of the
country he's been an organic coffee
farmer for years you feel proud when
your plants look like this producer sees
plants like this he's happy he's even
happier with the ground because of the
many shade trees and weeds the grounds
become more fertile so fungi and
microorganisms organic materials that
break down and decay
it comes from leaves that fall from the
trees they contain calcium magnesium and
other materials that means that the
Finca nourishes itself with the organic
Metheny report the plantation owner has
been practicing environmentally friendly
methods for some time now and it's hoped
that within the next two years an
additional six thousand coffee farmers
will join him
that would bring Costa Rica one step
closer to being carbon neutral
[Music]
you